c'est le roman il se passe quoi
exactement
le peuple vous arrange manif oui les
gens sont pas contents julien les
cotons-tiges julien les cotons-tiges
hockey dans ma vidéo sur les oreilles
qui sifflent
il ya manifestement un passage qui vous
a interpellé n'utilisez pas de coton
tige ça vous a fait pas mal réagir en
même temps c'est vrai si on peut pas
utiliser de coton tige comment on fait
pour se laver les oreilles et ben ça
c'est bon alors prenons problème à la
base
la première question déjà c'est pourquoi
est ce qu'il faudrait se nettoyer les
oreilles finalement oui c'est vrai c'est
quoi le problème en fait je sais le
problème c'est le cérumen c'est jaune
c'est poisseux ces salles quoi ben non
le cérumen il est utile il est même
super important parce qu'il protège le
conduit auditif et le tympan
il empêche l'eau de rentrer et d'aller
trop loin et il permet d'évacuer un
certain nombre de cochonneries comme des
poussières tous des bactéries
donc on en a besoin donc faut pas
retirer celui qui à l'intérieur de
l'oreille il faut pas aller le chercher
enlever celui qui sort de l'oreille et
qui est visible de l'extérieur ça on
peut c'est même plutôt une bonne idée
le problème avec les cotons-tiges c'est
que non seulement ils peuvent abîmer le
conduit auditif et même le tympan si
vous êtes vraiment une brute mais qu'en
plus ils poussent une partie du cérumen
dans le fond et que ça peut provoquer
des bouchons hirata est bon et alors
comment on nettoie les oreilles ok je
vais vous révéler un secret il y a moyen
il ya même un outil totalement adapté
est absolument parfait pour ça tellement
parfait qu'on lui a donné un nom
parfaitement adapté à cette fonction et
cet objet c
l'auriculaire le petit doigt
littéralement auriculaire c'est tout ce
qui se rapporte à l'oreille
oui il y avait un lundi donc
concrètement ce qu'il faut nettoyer
c'est le pavillon c'est à dire la partie
externe de l'oreille et l'entrée du
conduit
mais juste l'entrée pour retirer ce qui
coule et là encore cet objet extrêmement
bien fait parce que il vous suffit de
nettoyer juste là où votre petit doigt
peut aller et surtout on sait pas pour
essayer d'aller plus loin ça sert à rien
globalement c'est valable pour tous vos
orifices nettoyer l'entrée mais à les
patrons ont conduit du coup pour vous
laver les oreilles quand vous êtes sous
la douche mais utiliser de l'eau est un
peu de savon qui vous voulez vous pouvez
aussi faire ça au lavabo dans les mêmes
conditions et vous pouvez même utiliser
un petit linge mouillé
si vous avez les anglos par exemple
alors on va essayer de vous vendre tout
un tas d'autres dispositifs pour vous
laver les oreilles comme des bougies
d'oreilles par exemple oui des bougies à
la cire d'abeille qui sont censés
dissoudre et aspirer les bouchons et les
résidus de cérumen les rares études
menées sur cette technique ont démontré
que non seulement ça marchait pas mais
qu'en plus ça pouvait potentiellement
être dangereux parce que ça peut laisser
des dépôts laissé tomber sauf si vous
faites un qui fait tilt schiste autour
du fait des marchands de l'uimm
il ya aussi les spray nettoyant bon là a
priori c'est sans danger mais c'est
absolument pas nécessaires au quotidien
le mieux c'est de garder ça pour quand
vous ressentez une petite gêne parce que
parfois on produit plus de cérumen que
d'habitude alors pour plein de raisons 1
trop de poussière un nettoyage trop
agressif une inflammation et c est
parfois aussi on l'évacué moins bien
chez les personnes âgées par exemple
donc dans tous ces cas là ok un petit
coup de spray mais pas systématiquement
voilà vous savez maintenant comment vous
l'avez les oreilles 100 coton tige si
vous avez d'autres questions n'hésitez
pas à me les poser sur la page facebook
de dtc ou par mail à l'adresse question
dtc @ gmail point com dtc c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve bientôt
pour une
nouvelle vidéo d'ici là prenez soin de
vous prenez soin de vos oreilles
prenez soin des autres prenez soin de
toutes les personnes qui vous importent
et de tout ce que vous voulez finalement
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un beau message dans voilà